y
[Música]
cuando estaba a punto de cumplir un año
en la caja blanca el presidente de
estadounidense joe biden habló sobre los
aciertos y desaciertos de su primer
aniversario como mandatario defendió su
gestión sobre la pandemia y habló a
propósito del aumento histórico de la
inflación maiden advirtió que si rusia
invade a ucrania pagará sanciones sin
precedentes
el primer ministro del reino unido-
boris johnson se niega a renunciar esto
a pesar de la creciente presión que
enfrenta en el parlamento por las
fiestas en su residencia oficial cuando
su gobierno impedía las reuniones por
pandemia johnson también enfrenta una
revuelta interna de los conservadores
el cómic 19 se está propagando por
américa más rápido que nunca y todo por
la variante omicron así lo advirtió la
organización panamericana de la salud el
organismo urge a frenar el virus que
sigue registrando récords como en brasil
que por primera vez superó los 200 mil
casos diarios tenemos reporte en minutos
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 mi nombre es
maría clara calle y los acompañaré en
este recorrido y empezamos en eeuu el
presidente joe biden cumple este jueves
su primer año al frente de la casa
blanca desde washington respondió a los
cuestionamientos que le hicieron en una
rueda de prensa sobre los logros y los
desaciertos de su administración a nivel
interno las críticas se enfocaron en su
manejo de la pandemia y en el incremento
de la inflación que se encuentra en el
nivel más alto en 40 años en el panorama
internacional baiden aseguró que cree
que rusia procederá a agredir a ucrania
y le advirtió a ese país que si lo hace
podría enfrentar un desastre el
mandatario añadió que las sanciones
serían sin precedentes yo pienso que lo
que ustedes van a ver es que rusia
tendrá que rendir cuentas y invade
y depende de lo que haga una cosa es si
ocurre una inclusión menor y terminamos
discutiendo sobre qué hacer y qué no
hacer
pero si realmente hacen lo que son
capaces de hacer con las fuerzas
acumuladas en la frontera va a ser un
desastre para rouse y continúan
invadiendo ucrania
nuestros aliados y socios están listos
para imponer costos severos y un daño
significativo a rusia y la economía rusa
y
también en eeuu un nuevo golpe para los
demócratas en el senado la minoría
republicana bloqueó el proyecto de ley
sobre la reforma al derecho al voto
impulsada desde la casa blanca dicha
reforma buscaba entre otros expandir el
voto anticipado y hacer del día de
elecciones un festivo federal los
republicanos que votaron en bloque
utilizaron la amenaza del filibustero
para bloquear la iniciativa que según
grupos de defensa de derechos civiles es
vital para proteger la democracia
estadounidense así las cosas la mayoría
demócrata procederá a intentar cambiar
las reglas del procedimiento de
obstruccionismo el filibustero para
convertirlo nuevamente en un filibustero
hablado sin embargo dicho esfuerzo
también fracasaría pues al menos dos
senadores demócratas se oponen a los
cambios en las reglas de la cámara alta
y el primer ministro británico boris
johnson se rehúsa a renunciar a pesar de
que así lo piden los laboristas y cada
vez más conservadores de la cámara de
los comunes el premier enfrentó a los
parlamentarios tras el escándalo de las
fiestas realizadas en downing street en
pleno confinamiento de la pandemia
johnson afirmó que no dimitirá siete
conservadores ya enviaron cartas y se
espera que otros veinte hagan lo mismo
para pedir una moción de confianza que
podría terminar en la destitución del
primer ministro del reino unido se
necesitan al menos 54 de estas
solicitudes esto es lo que dicen los
laboristas y lo que dice yo
el año pasado su majestad estaba sola en
el funeral del hombre con el que estuvo
casada durante 73 años en la vigilia de
ese funeral se llenó una maleta con
alcohol y se llevó a downing street
donde tocó un dj y el personal festejo
hasta tarde
teniendo en cuenta que el primer
ministro viktor las normas porque creen
que esta nueva defensa va a funcionar
absolutamente claro el honorable
caballero sigue haciendo preguntas que
sabe que serán abordadas en su totalidad
por la investigación está perdiendo el
tiempo de la cámara y el tiempo de la
gente
pasamos a noticias del hobby 19 la
organización panamericana de la salud
afirmó que este virus se está propagando
por américa más activamente que nunca en
la región se reportaron 72 millones de
contagios la semana pasada y por esto la
vp s la ope se recomendó que las pruebas
rápidas de antígenos se prioricen para
quienes tienen síntomas aunque el
organismo aclaró que los efectos de la
variante omicron parecen más leves que
los de otros linajes también reconoció
que las hospitalizaciones por kobe 19
están aumentando en varios países
seguimos instando que haya precaución y
cautela porque el virus se está
esparciendo mucho más activamente que
antes que nunca antes lo cual significa
que es de gran importancia proteger
nuestros sistemas de salud para que las
personas que necesitan atención puedan
recibirla y contar con ella y la mejor
manera para proteger a nuestros sistemas
de salud es vacunar nos cuando sea
nuestro turno las vacunas nos protegen
de los peores síntomas de comida y
reducen las probabilidades de tener que
hospitalizar nos a propósito de esto en
brasil se confirmaron por primera vez
más de 200.000 contagios en un solo día
éste repuntó del cob y 19 se debe a gran
medida a la variante omicron que
representa el 90% de los nuevos
diagnósticos 15 de los 27 estados
brasileños están en alerta pues su tasa
de ocupación de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos supera el 60% según dijo el
centro de investigación fiocruz nuestra
corresponsal valeria saccone nos trae
más
por primera vez desde el inicio de la
pandemia de coronavirus o brasil supera
los 205 mil contagios diarios
registrados y la media semanal también
preocupa porque se sitúa por primera vez
por encima de los 100 mil casos diarios
eso en el medio de la ola de lo micro
que ha llegado a brasil hace ya unas
semanas sin embargo las autoridades
sanitarias han tardado en darse cuenta
de la gravedad de la situación porque el
10 de diciembre el sistema informático
del ministerio de salud fue saboteado
por un grupo de hackers y se que no
fuera del aire durante más de un mes ha
sido solo a principios de este mes que
el suministro de datos de los varios
estados federados ha sido restablecido y
ha sido cuando el estado se ha dado
cuenta lo que realmente estaba
aconteciendo en brasil de momento el
número de muertes no es excesivamente
altos 349 en las últimas 24 horas son
datos que quedan muy lejos de los más de
4.000 muertos diarios que tuvimos en el
país en el pasado mes de abril sin
embargo preocupa
porque las últimas dos semanas ha habido
un incremento del 114 por ciento de la
mortalidad mientras brasil no ha
adoptado ninguna medida de restricción
en pleno verano las playas del río de
janiero están abarrotadas y aunque
algunos bares y algunas escuelas de
samba han interrumpido su programación
la ciudad los restaurantes las calles
los espectáculos están llenos y parece
que nadie está realmente preocupado por
esta nueva ola de contagios las costas
de perú siguen negras por el derrame de
más de 6000 barriles de petróleo el
gobierno de pescadores piden
indemnizaciones a la empresa española
repsol pero la compañía afirma que todo
se ocasionó por el tsunami que hubo tras
la erupción de un volcán en la isla de
tonga asociaciones denunció en una grave
afectación al medio ambiente
uno de los peores desastres ecológicos
de la historia reciente de perú la
erupción del volcán submarino de tonga a
10.000 kilómetros dejó graves
consecuencias al menos 18 mil kilómetros
cuadrados se han visto afectados por el
derrame de 6.000 barriles de petróleo en
el norte de lima y en la región de
callao las grandes olas afectaron a un
buque italiano que estaba cargando fuel
en la refinería de la pampilla la
cancillería de perú señala como
responsable a la petrolera española
repsol el derrame de petróleo de repsol
en ventanilla es el peor desastre
ecológico ocurrido en lima en los
últimos tiempos y ha ocasionado un grave
perjuicio a cientos de familias de
pescadores repsol debe resarcir este año
de manera inmediata
se habrían visto afectadas siete
asociaciones de pescadores
decenas se concentraron en las
instalaciones de la región de callao
junto a la capital de lima para exigir
recompensas lo que queremos que
reconozca los daños que han cometido
ellos nuestro fuente de trabajo o sea
que nos tenéis que dar
repsol niega su responsabilidad y
asegura que estás realizando tareas de
limpieza mientras apuntan que a
diferencia de ecuador y chile la marina
peruana no avisó de la posibilidad de
tsunami pero el daño además de económico
y para el sector de la pesca ha afectado
a la fauna especialmente a aves habría
causado un gran impacto
no solamente al elemento agua sino a
todos los seres vivos que hay sobre este
elemento agua y el suelo de las playas
son las consecuencias del volcán de
tonga que también dejaron el
fallecimiento de dos mujeres el sábado
pero pasan los días y el mar sigue
estando negro hasta aquí las noticias
sigan en france 24
[Música]